communicate with men like men that they
can I've seen women boss up in men's
faces like push men and all this kind of
stuff and I'm like
do you understand that kind of do you
understand what that means no I hear you
I want to speak because I've had an
experience
um of acting as such a man I had to
check myself as a result of seeing
myself and when I speak about my
experience the only thing that I was
able to make sense of is the fact that I
come from a similar environment that has
conditioned me to quote unquote Express
relative masculine energy and
expressions and I had to see it in
myself to realize that you're not acting
like a lady but at the same time I come
from a single parent home I'm from
quote-unquote South London I used to
fight I love when I was younger I used
to be really into sports so in my
younger years for the most I used to be
a tomboy like when I my mum it was just
my mum me and my sisters so when someone
comes to the door I used to be to go to
the door something's broken in the house
I so I didn't even realize I was being
conditioned and adopting some of these
masculine traits so when I am when I
used to find myself in quote-unquote
conversation arguments I didn't realize
that I was rather than famine and
squaring up but it took me a while to
really do you ever get punched in the
face by me I did actually did you yeah I
did
how is your face not like he had to slap
do you not punch Oh no I got punched
about it wasn't me it wasn't I'm just
thinking if a dude hit you full force it
was your face it wasn't full force the
personal question wasn't yeah
um yeah um and that was my only ever
experience in doing that but I just I I
even though I do feel like I was
antagonized the person played a part in
it I do see how I facilitated that when
I checked myself where did I come from
why did you act like that you can
communicate in all manner that can you
know get better results and I understand
that that's not effective when you're
actually trying to get results with men
I thought where did that come from and I
realized you know what it came from how
I got brought up I used to pretty much
act like a boy so they should speak like
a boy it's like a self-dundance girl but
it's taking me a while past 25 to
realize that you know what you actually
just because you of where you come from
doesn't mean you can't be feminine and
use your femininity to get results when
it comes to interactive women so well
well done for doing the work on yourself
do you
um because
I've seen um
you see with that type of woman that
type of communication where where women
think that they're men
I've been out like on a night out right
and I've seen women
who feel this who feel aggrieved about a
way a man neither spoke to her or
treated her a certain way and she's been
up in a man's Facebook about she's been
with her boyfriend that's the worst
right that's the worst time Lord have
mercy one of my things is
because women are women they don't
understand what danger is right you
don't know and women understand danger
when it comes to other men like sexual
danger grape and sexual assault and that
kinds of stuff those kind of stuff but
when it comes to that physical violent
danger I feel like women don't
understand what it is and it's like I've
seen on a couple of occasions a woman
with a boyfriend and she's another man
has been with like five dudes and she's
been rapping and I've been like you are
about to let your boyfriend die today
like your boyfriend's gonna get effed up
today because you don't understand that
if you don't learn to shut the f up
right your boyfriend's gonna have to
jump in and defend you right and he's
gonna get jumped by about like five
dudes my members say you're on your own
mate
there's no way my man gonna jump in to
see me if I start some rubbish like that
women like that
dangerous that's what men need to do men
need to wise up to women when they're
doing that rubbish ever us every woman
approach you just walk away and leave
her
I would say slap her Dan but if there's
the cameras around myself and men they
they just need to wise up if I get my if
I went out there with my men and I
started an argument he was saying like
is that what your brain told you to say
it'd be like
he's like um um check yourself I'm like
do you know what's funny because you
stop me there check yourself my cell
phone powered on it I'm just gonna say
an anecdotal little story anecdotal
Story Time myself and power done a
podcast with a certain woman and um
let's just say this woman did not like
me very much on the podcast right we had
issues and
what I what what happened was is that I
think she didn't mind you at the podcast
I think it was the edits that came it
was edit yeah so once the edits came out
and the clips came out she didn't like
me like she went on some this guy's this
and he's I don't like Sarah and blah
blah blah and um I saw her again like a
couple months later and I was just like
listen yo no beef here like no we're
cool she's like I don't like you and
like a couple of days later like in my
inbox on like Instagram her boyfriend
had come in my inbox I don't like the
way you spoke to my girl
and I was like you know what whatever
she told you she's put a battery in your
back bro and I'm not saying that I'm a
gangster or anything like that but women
like that will literally send their man
out into the field to go and defend
their honor Mama right yeah defend my
honor and then when the guy gets Eva
into trouble with the police or effed up
she's nowhere to be seen when the
bullets start flying women not know what
to be seen women will gas a guy up like
to go and get effed up and there'll be
nowhere to be seen afterwards and it may
need to get wise that it needs to get
why it's broken
composure it's so easy to put a man in
his place without having to get yourself
out of it why would you want to be
putting them out
in this place do you know what men have
been doing when they come up to me now
on the streets some of them they don't
seem to like me very much from this
podcast so they tend to man handle me
grab me a bit too tough on the shoulder
slap my shoulders a bit too hard and I'm
like listen this guy's about to really
piss me off but it's okay and I tell him
every single time with my composure
don't forget I'm still a woman who are
you to be manhandling me like that
please take your hands off me easy you
don't need to get angry he feels stupid
and he leaves you alone that's all you
need so I think that sometimes like
girls
take a deep breath and hit the nail on
the head with what you say composure
just Twisted that was your best point
it's that whole situation right he was
talking about the women going out there
and making their mango arm and she just
twists
in a woman we weren't talking about a
man touching a woman no I'm just saying
shut their mouth don't have composure to
be more feminine
and to maybe learn to think before you
speak hey because you think
you think that it's always us looking
for trouble
for trouble for me all the time because
you don't go looking for trouble no why
would a man come and put his hand on you
well ask him because I told him I'm
storming don't put your hand on me
what's wrong with you why are you
talking what do you think who do you
think caps more men about how much they
get laid or women about how much they
get approached women about how much they
can approach that's what every girl says
and you know what a guy said to me he
saw me on the tube the camera don't do
your Justice and I was like well thank
you that's a good way to approach me I
believe in equal rights equal laughs I
feel like if you hit someone you should
get hit back say that not right
yeah isn't it I just feel like if you I
wouldn't hit someone and not expect to
get hit back and be like oh you hit me I
think the reactive thing is also
especially squaring lots of people
outside when you're under the influence
and you've got this extra gas in you
that you can do it until you get hit
you're like oh my God I can't believe
what I've just done yeah
[Laughter]
it's never my thing to do and I've
watched how my mum behaves or moves of
just how much she doesn't have to do
anything I mean but you people do get
triggered and if they feel like they're
in a situation it's reminding them of
when this person did this and they're
getting everything that that person did
before so yeah being reflective and
realizing what the situation actually is
before reacting I think is important I
was looking past physicality as well
because obviously men are physically
bigger than us and they might have
certain mannerisms that might make you
feel threatened but it's not intentional
that doesn't mean that you can now try
and use your body to try and intimidate
him back
so this calm down and think about it
calm down go away and come back and
think about before you act if more women
will stop take a deep breath think it
through walk away and come back don't do
anything when you're upset don't do
anything when you're emotional don't
even cook because when you cook when
you're emotional the food don't do
nothing what if you're emotional shut
yourself down God you know what say that
sorry love but you know what any time
alone right now because you know what I
mean like it's [ __ ] go away the men
will understand that yeah I'm crazy I
need an hour
I'd say this [ __ ] like if you're an
attractive woman you need to understand
like
you are inherently dangerous to your men
like when you're walking down the street
as a man it's more dangerous walking
down the road with an attractive woman
than it is a gold chains around your
neck like I took my girl to Carnival
like we just thought yeah went to
Westfield we'll go for a walk yeah right
we'll go through we'll go and walk
through Carnival see what it's saying
yeah
dangerous situation Carnival bro
dangerous situation you're asking for
trouble yeah
people are troubled things
as guys that say people are troubling
people's elbows and truck Carnival bro
your elbow is not safe every elbow your
elbow is not safe in carnival and and
for her it was a big eye-opening as well
because she realized that right like
it's actually dangerous me walking down
the road with you so I need to actually
carry myself in a certain type of way
where I'm not going to attract any
attention or danger I mean but a lot of
women don't actually realize this they
don't actually clock how dangerous it is
you know I know that was a bit of a
woman that dress sexy when they go
outside but how sexy are they when
they're at home for their man right and
it's more dangerous to be inside sexier
than your man women need to get more
sexy for the men indoors save the
laundry for at home he's like going out
of your menu with your titties out and
your ass is dangerous yeah because
because all it all it takes is one guy
to be to cackle you or try and grab you
and your man's not looking and then
there's a situation you imagine I gotta
defend your honor that's right a whole
issue that didn't need to happen no but
it's just it's just like just dress
through some kind of class in decorum do
you know what I mean like you can still
be sexy you can still be sexy but classy
classy at the same time like you don't
need to be showing all your stuff
no yeah because I kind of like
sensuality I like being able to be free
I mean not saying that I need to be have
a battery Riders out my tits out all the
time but I want my man or whoever I'm
going to be secure in the fact that not
that you're insecure if I'm getting
um approached but that that's you're
with me you know what you know what this
is but like you want guys to be looking
at looking at your woman like even if
you clothes on or not they're going to
do that if you're on a channel
you don't think there's a difference
between like wearing like a super tight
dress and like a flowy one just to be a
little bit more respected when you got
hips and thighs and breasts you can't
always hide it and sometimes I'm I could
be in a if I was wearing a dress that
you're wearing now I'd still probably
have enough relaxed I understand that
like different body types but you don't
you have some dresses that are more
conservative and some that are more
revealing and wouldn't it if you're in a
relationship make more sense to where
your more conservative dresses
I want to ask a question about that
because ultimately
doesn't that that you sometimes want to
also see me sexy because I'm not going
to wear the tight dress as women as as
women you have standards yourself like
you know like I can't have my boobs and
my legs out okay you know I mean so
you've got things
like you can't you if you're going to go
out of your mind for dinner and you've
got your as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible